to say there's a lot at stake here in
glasgow is an understatement the science
tells us what needs to be done and we'll
see in the halls behind me over the next
two weeks if national leaderships have
what it takes to step up the world is
overheating and extreme weather is
already hitting hard and to demonstrate
the importance of this conference we
return to evia in greece scene of those
devastating wildfires in the summer
where they're still picking up the
pieces
in early august with temperatures at
unseen highs wildfires ripped across
southern europe
the land was parched and the fires
quickly spread northern avia in greece
was the hardest hit
the inferno lasted for two weeks
thousands were
evacuated today you can see what's left
the devastation in this area was total
people are well used to annual wildfires
here but not on this scale not with this
much lost
thousands of hectares of forest and
livelihoods just incinerated
and because of the fires a new threat as
the rain comes so do floods and
mudslides
the fires have destroyed the land's
natural ability to withhold water to act
as a flood defense system so now in
periods of intense rain the water just
cascades
off these hillsides
so they're using the dead trees to shore
up the soil and keep the land intact
it is hard exhausting work but vital to
preserve what's left and encourage
regeneration of the forest
a big part of evia's forest economy has
been obliterated
costas ionus livelihood comes from his
bees who make honey from the resin of
pine trees or used to i feel sad that
this once green forest has been burnt
and i find it difficult to figure out
what we'll do and how beekeeping can
continue to exist on evia we will not be
around when this forest is once again
able to give us honey so for us our area
has died
collecting pine resin was an important
money earner for farmers like georgios
agnostu but not anymore he also lost a
fifth of his goat herd to the fires
across the island more animals died than
survived
the destruction was great for farmers
buildings were burnt animals were lost
and grazing land has disappeared in
other words what we had here was lost
many years need to go by so that things
can return to how they were
helping people around the world to adapt
to and mitigate against catastrophic
events like this is a big part of the
climate conference in glasgow
so what a success that cop 26 look like
the science tells us we need to prevent
temperatures from rising beyond ideally
one and a half degrees celsius but the
2021 production gap report shows that
current government plans will produce
more than double the amount of fossil
fuels required to make that happen so in
glasgow we need a strong declaration
that commits to net zero emissions by
2050 as well as big reductions by 2030
this has been a seismic event that has
changed lives perhaps for a generation
but the forest will come back because
nature always does
if humanity allows it to
well right now the omens here in glasgow
are not good just this week we heard
that even with the latest global
commitments to cut emissions we're still
heading for 2.7 degrees celsius and
remember the target is one and a half
degrees and the 100 billion dollars a
year promised by rich nations to
developing countries by 2020 well that
won't arrive now until 2023
trust is a limited commodity here in
glasgow and it will be a long hard
battle to reach the agreement the world
needs